all right so today president trump
announced that the person allegedly
responsible for the mail bomb scare
is now thankfully in custody let's take
a look
i am pleased to inform you that law
enforcement
has apprehended the suspect
and taken him into custody
it's an incredible job by law
enforcement we've carried out a far
reaching federal state and local
investigation
to find the person or persons
responsible for these events
these terrorizing acts are despicable
and have
no place in our country no place
i've instructed authorities to spare no
resource or expense in finding those
responsible and bringing them
to swift and certain justice we must
never allow
political violence to take root in
america
cannot let it happen and i'm committed
to doing
everything in my power as president to
stop
it and to stop it
amen and tonight federal officials they
are continuing their important
investigation but thanks to
their hard work their dedication their
determination
here's what we know about this suspect
his name cesar
sayoc now he's a middle-aged florida
resident with an extremely long
criminal track record including multiple
counts of theft
drug charges illicit steroid use and
much more
he was even charged with making a bomb
threat back in 2002
and throughout his life sayoc has
accumulated dozens of felony and
misdemeanor charges
and he reportedly filed for bankruptcy
in 2012 when he lived with his mother
now his van was covered with dozens of
bizarre bumper stickers including many
that were derogatory
some threatening to democrats his
multiple me social media accounts were
equally odd very disturbing
and as you can see this is the picture
of an irrational man who is deeply
deeply troubled
and like the president said we want
anybody
anybody responsible for this heinous
bomb scare to be held responsible
to the fullest extent of the law if
sayoc is found guilty
he should go to prison for an extremely
long period of time these actions are
deplorable inexcusable
there is no room for political violence
in this country
we solve our problems like in 11 days at
the ballot box
and as as i've said many times is a very
serious story
but over the course of this week what we
have seen
what we have witnessed in the mainstream
media and the left
has been downright disgraceful before
ever
even knowing who was responsible for
this heinous act the media started
playing the blame game
rushing to judgment as usual they put
facts
last they rushed to judgment and they
did anything and
everything possible to link president
trump and anyone who supports him
to this act of terrorism even the
graphics on fake news cnn
blaming trump calling the would-be bomb
victim
quote trump's targets trump's targets
believe it or not
the vitriol was far worse on air now
watch from just the past 24 hours
it should make your heart well sink
but the list of targets was right out of
trump's relentless rhetorical playbook
the bomber's enemies were his enemies he
has said so again and again
and again everybody should stop
pretending that trump
doesn't really know what he's doing um
that when he
uh when he says these things he knows
exactly what he's trying to encourage
donald trump fails the country he
doesn't just fail democrats
he fails democrats and republicans and
all of all americans in between
he's refused to in any way acknowledge
what role his rhetoric may have
played in cultivating the current
political climate this president has an
obligation
to stop picking on reporters the
president has created a
culture of comfort for violent rhetoric
and
and actual violence he spends most of
his time
at his rallies throwing verbal bombs
at all the people that receive these
bombs in the mail
and one fake news cnn political analyst
even blaming yours truly for the bomb
scare especially as it relates to robert
de niro this is a disgrace
watch this i just want to go back to
that for a second because everybody said
why robert de niro he didn't
he hasn't criticized the president since
the tony awards in june but you found
that it's
what happened what sean hannity says had
a direct link
mayhem we don't we don't know who it is
we don't know the motive but what was
fascinating is
you see a direct pattern between the
president's attacks on twitter and and
the stage
it being echoed and amplified by fox
news and other folks in the conservative
agency but deniro's not like the others
right why robert de niro well one of the
things i found was is that october 15th
sean hannity was doing a whole segment
blasting de niro for things he said on
the alec baldwin show of all things in
which he said that trump allies will
regret it because they made a deal with
the devil so that all of a sudden
becomes
trump robert de niro's calling the
president devil and us devil worshipers
in effect you know
um it's the playing the victim card but
it was top of mind 10 days ago and
essentially they'll be see
what is that when we find out who this
is now john avalon is both lying and
he's ignorant and frankly
recklessly irresponsible now he is the
walking embodiment of why
so many americans just don't trust the
media
why they chant cnn sucks maybe you
should
actually watch a full episode of hannity
or listen to my radio show
then he would actually see how i have
been repeatedly
calling on political vilification in
this country to stop
especially the confrontations how i
deplore
disavow all incivility and acts of
violence from
the left and the right by the way if
avalon ever watched my show listen my
radio show
he would know how much i value law
and order and the safety of everyone
including people
i disagree with passionately for example
when president obama's security was
threatened in 2014
i spoke out over and over and over again
how we need to protect
our president even though i had strong
disagreements with him
watch this we have three incidents we
have the fence jumper
made it much further into the white
house even past the stairs going up to
the residents
which is scary uh we have the second
incident in 2011
six shots fired at the white house and
took them four days to determine that
they thought it had nothing
related to do with the white house which
i disagree with and then a guy with a
gun got
on an elevator with the president of the
united states
isis our enemies are watching this we've
got to protect our president
every elected official every cabinet
member every member of congress the
senate deserves security
everyone deserves safety and by the way
my heart goes out to anyone who's ever
been threatened or harmed
because you know what i know firsthand
how it feels i've been through more than
frankly i'm willing
to make public including white powder
mailed to me
telling me it's anthrax i had an
assistant of mine scared to death
put in isolation for hours as a result
of one incident
and i've had numerous other real threats
in my career to both myself and my
family
lunatics they have no political
boundaries and to suggest
that honest vigorous hard-hitting debate
and criticism
is somehow the motivating force behind
one fringe violent individual
is intellectually lazy john avalon and
frankly
just nothing but a cheap attempt to
capitalize
off a serious incident you should be
ashamed of yourself
and remember i never blamed bernie
sanders because one of his loyal
supporters
shot republican lawmakers nearly killed
steve scalise on a baseball field last
year as a matter of fact i said the
opposite take a look
i'm not blaming bernie bernie sanders
supporters
no this was one nut remember the bernie
sanders supporter the one that targeted
republicans at baseball practice
leaving congressman steve scalise
fighting for his life
well was the media blaming democrats for
that
no and by the way they shouldn't have
and i don't blame bernie either
i don't blame bernie either it would be
irresponsible
to tie him to what one nut supporter
does i've said many times
there are deranged individuals on both
sides of the aisle
and they and they alone are responsible
for their evil actions and by the way
this brings us to our next point the
left's double standard
while the mainstream media now condemns
what they see
as destructive rhetoric from only the
right they may want to reflect inward
first per usual
in just the past 24 hours alone the
anti-trump vitriol from the mainstream
destroyed trump media has been downright
despicable
and we've got the tape take a look when
you
keep stirring that pot and you have
leaders the president of the united
states people listen to him he's no
longer on a talk show he's the president
of the united states
and this is whipping up people and you
will see people respond
he was elected to be president of the
united states not you know
you know a mental patient this is just
escalating and it's only probably going
to get worse if he doesn't change his
tone
maybe they should be lecturing maxine
waters and company
you know create a crowd follow them in
to grocery stores department stores gas
stations
they're not wanted anywhere anymore and
what you just saw is nothing new
because the left's hatred of all things
trump
has been boiling over since the day he
and melania came down the escalator
here's just a small sampling of the
insanity
if you see anybody from that cabinet in
a restaurant in a department store
at a gasoline station you get out and
you create a crowd
and you push back on them and you tell
them they're not
welcome you cannot be civil with a
political
party that wants to destroy
what you stand for what you care about
michelle wood says that you know when
they
go low we go no
they go low we kick he say the things he
does
of course i want to punch him in the
face right i want to send the military
to the white house to get him
yes i have thought an awful lot
about blowing up the white house when
was the last time
an actor assassinated the president it's
been a while
and maybe it's time tyrants number one
want to denigrate
the people that go about the fourth
estate the the journalists who go out
and try to determine
what the truth is i want to read the
definition of of treason
when do we see almost a shadow
government come out and say we cannot
side with the government we're oddly
influential with the guy who wants to
kill us
there's a sign out there that's been
hung up in the white house or outside
the white house saying
if you're not white you're not
especially welcome so you know what yeah
with rhetoric like that it's kind of odd
that they're now blaming donald trump
and his allies
for the actions of a lunatic especially
since multiple deranged
far left individuals have been what
we've been watching now for
weeks harassing attacking threatening
republicans all over the country just in
recent weeks
we've been warning you rand paul's been
warning you something
horrible is going to happen doesn't
matter if it's left or right
but the left silence when it's their
side
has been deafening and worse and some
elected officials
actually sent out marching orders to
harass
intimidate cabinet officials elected
officials and candidates
white powder mailed to the president
president trump uh
secretary of defense mattis fbi director
ray
cia director haspel that's just three
weeks ago
president's son was also targeted with a
suspicious package
don jr's ex-wife hospitalized because of
that package
a truck with a trump bumper sticker that
was set on fire
you have two republican candidates in
minnesota were punched
one a woman another a man with severe
injuries his cold [ __ ] from behind
six weeks bad concussion a republican
campaign manager in nevada
that he was assaulted there were dozens
more instant incidences of
vandalism assault harassment including
top republicans stalked in
airports run out of restaurants
repeatedly we've shown you this
videotape
and while we constantly condemn acts of
violence
on both sides of the aisle when
something happens to a conservative
all democrats have been missing in
action noticeably silent
we're going to have a lot more on this
throughout the show but first more big
news on the looming crisis at our
southern border tonight
the migrant caravan continues to move
north even as we speak
defense secretary mattis just approved a
request to send even more troops to the
border
now at least 800 soldiers of officially
being dispatched to bolster the efforts
of our border patrol agents
president trump recently told the
migrants in the caravan
said it again tonight turn back and now
he is reportedly mulling an executive
order to bar
entry of all migrants at the u.s mexico
border
which he has the authority to do